j'ai quelques problèmes avec le r dans
le mot
runification l'unification en tout cas
elle est bien en marche car les hommes
aujourd'hui se
rejoignent les deux Allemagne se
rapproche mais ce processus ne doit pas
nécessairement déboucher sur un seul et
même
état tout en fait dépendra de
l'évolution européenne
dans les années à venir l'est et l'ouest
de l'Europe vont se rapprocher aussi les
deux Allemagnes peut-être un peu plus
vite c'est
tout les Allemands dans leur majorité
comprennent bien une
chose la structure de ce futur État
allemand quelle qu'en soit la forme
devra correspondre à ce que nous voulons
nous en Allemagne mais aussi à ce que
nos voisins européens
et
raison justement il y a beaucoup de gens
en Europe de l'Ouest et notamment en
France qui craignent que la RFA n'oublie
un peu la construction européenne au
profit du pays frère de la RDA est-ce
que cette crainte selon vous est
justifiée non nous ne retirons rien à
notre engagement européen à
l'ouest la Communauté européenne de son
côté devra adopter une attitude nouvelle
face au pays de l'Est nouer avec eux des
relations
différentes quant à nous nous devrons
faire de même mais à l'égard de la RDA
après tout elle est plus proche de la
Communauté européenne que la Pologne par
exemple cela dit avant de trouver sa
place dans la communauté la RDA a encore
un long chemin à parcourir
voilà chaque instant l'actualité évolue
je vous le laisser entendre tout à
l'heure à l'instant je lis sur mon petit
ordinateur le réformateur Hans modro a
été élu chef de gouvernement en
Allemagne de l'Est par le Parlement est
allemand il a été élu tout à
l'heure il était l'unique candidat il é
élu à l'unanimité voilà